[Music]
welcome to Bible answers live where
you'll get honest answers to your Bible
questions let's face it it's not always
easy to understand everything you read
in the Bible with 66 books and more than
700 thousand words the Bible can
generate a lot of questions if you'd
like answers to your Bible questions
you've come to the right place now
here's your host pastor Doug Batchelor
president and speaker of amazing facts
hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact on February 4 2019 a man
was jogging through West Ridge Trail
near Fort Collins Colorado and he killed
a mountain lion with his bare hands
after the animal attacked him the man
reportedly heard something behind him
while he was running and turned just in
time to see the animal lunge at him what
followed next was a ferocious wrestling
match as a hungry 80 pound cat bit the
man about his face and his wrists he
managed to pick up a rock with his free
hand and slam the lion on the head he
then jumped on the animals back and
choked it to death with his hands and
arms fearing if you let it go it would
resume its attack he sustained some
serious injuries to the face and wrists
but he still managed to alert
authorities can get himself to a
hospital on his own accord after
receiving several stitches the man was
released from the hospital and
thankfully is expected to make a full
recovery
authorities later found the lion and
confirmed it died via suffocation
Colorado Parks and Wildlife is
withholding than the name of the man at
his request he'd like some time to
recover before he speaks for the media
you know the Bible tells of several
accounts of men that wrestled with lions
and won and stay with his friends were
going to learn more on this edition of
Bible answers live
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
honest answers to your Bible questions
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode to receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this evening's
program call 888-814-3923
800 got your pencil for 63 72 97 callin
now with your Bible questions got a
great opportunity of getting it on
tonight's program
we're also streaming this live on
Facebook if you go to the amazing facts
Facebook page or the Doug Batchelor
Facebook page you'll see for whatever
it's worth you'll see actually the
visual the video and you can watch there
and call into your questions as well my
name is Doug Batchelor
my name is John Ross good evening pastor
Doug and Friends would be glad to be
able to do Bible answers live but before
we get to the phone lines pass today we
always like to start with prayer dear
father in heaven we thank you once again
that we do have this opportunity to
spend some time in your word and we do
ask for the Holy Spirit to guide our
hearts and our forces we search the
scriptures for Bible answers in Jesus
name Amen amen
pastor day you open the program but
talking about well something you don't
hear about too often an attack between a
lion and a man and the man comes out on
top and he didn't have a gun or a knife
he just grabbed a hold of what he could
find which was a rock and it was
actually able to kill the lion and you
know escape certain death
a normal circumstances you think but you
didn't mention he was a fairly strong
guy I guess he was an athlete maybe
jogging out on the trail yeah
the lion picked the wrong guy he was a
pretty good shape from what I read and
you know when you're fighting for your
life he's that adrenaline running yeah I
think it was also a younger line a
little less experienced and he bit off
more than he could chew
quite literally but it makes me think of
Oh about three stories in the Bible
where men wrestled with lines or fought
them David it says he took the lion by
the beard and smote it and we don't know
exactly what that means but Lions do
have the you know the Asian Lions do
have the the males the beard as well as
the mane and and then it tell us about
Samson who picked up a line a young lion
roared at him and he tore it as one
would tear a kid he you know pretty
strong biceps or something and then
there was one of the mighty men of David
I don't remember his name but he jumped
into a pit and on a winter day and he
killed a lion I think with a spear so
when you read these stories in the Bible
a lion in the Bible is often synonymous
with the devil for instance in first
Peter 5:8 be sober be vigilant because
your adversary the devil walks around
like a roaring lion seeking whom he may
devour the devil is often trying to
catch his prey by some surprise through
ambush but the Lord tells us that we
through God's power can defeat the lion
in fact in Psalm 91 verse 13 he says you
will tread upon the lion in the Cobra
two symbols of the devil the young lion
and the serpent you will trample
underfoot and so with the help of the
Lord we can resist the devil and his on
slots and Satan is you know he's not
trying to physically eat us but he tries
to bring us down through his temptations
and his distractions to discourage our
faith and we can resist his temptations
in his efforts to discourage us through
the word now we have a free offer that
will tell you how you can defeat the
lion that we're gonna make available to
anyone who calls tonight the free offer
that we have tonight is a very practical
book and I think it's something that
ever
Christian recognizes as something we
need in allies to be victorious
Christians it's called tips for
resisting temptation it's actually a
book that you wrote pass today and we'll
be happy to send this out to anyone who
calls and ask is very practical deals
with these real issues again it's called
tips for resisting temptation that is
our free offer and if you'd like to
receive the book call our resource phone
line eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven that number again this
is the resource phone line is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven and you can ask for the book
called tips for resisting temptation for
those of you who might be watching on
Facebook even outside of North America
you can read this book by going to the
amazing facts website and just search
the in the library for the book called
tips for resisting temptation and I
think you'll be able to read it right
there online well our first call of this
evening is Rodney listening from North
Carolina
Rodney welcome to the program you're on
the air well hello hello evening good
evening pastor doug and pastor ross yes
how can we help you tonight okay I got a
question something been nagging at me
for awhile I've been looking through the
Bible and I've been noticing that well
starting in Leviticus mostly in
Leviticus concerning laying your hands
on an animal and transferring the sins
to the animal and they go out in the
wilderness and another example was
Leviticus 16 and 21 where this gentleman
strove with a young guy and the young
guy started getting upset and says in
verse 10 the son of the Israelitish
woman whose father was an Egyptian went
out among the children of Israel and
this son of is Israelitish woman and a
man of Israel strove together in the
count it goes on to say that he cursed
God and everything and then they have
all the people to come out and the
witnesses that were sure's that
sure of what he did they were the ones
who stoned this guy they firstly put
that on him on his head getting back to
Matt through and then ah the gospel no
Gospels different ones was sealed by
Jesus but he never touched their head
and here's my question out the reason
out of that and trying to come to some
conclusion I want to know from your
opinion is it biblical for an elder or
pastor other leader to touch another
person's head while praying for them
yeah he in a word you do have cases
where jesus healed people through touch
in I think it's Luke chapter five a
leper came to Jesus he said Lord if
you're willing you can make me clean it
says Jesus reached out touched him and
said I am willing be clean
sometimes Jesus touched people he
touched a blind man's eyes he put some
mud on his eyes sometimes Jesus spoke
and He healed a person sometimes they
reached out and touched him in the Bible
touch often represents transferring what
a father blessed his child he would lay
hands on the fur on the head of the sons
and transfer a blessing this is what
Jacob did for I'm sorry what Isaac did
for Jacob Jacob later did for his sons
and grandsons you could also transfer
sin which has happened what happens in
Leviticus from the high priest would
confess the sins of the people he placed
his hands on the head of the the goats
on the day of atonement and you know it
could transfer authority when Jesus put
his hands on the apostles or when the
apostles later anointed or ordained
deacons and elders they would transfer
authority by placing their hands so the
placing of the hands represented a
transfer of authority now the story that
you give in Leviticus about the the man
that cursed God he was later stoned and
that's really just a court process where
the the witnesses said we heard it you
know they were some of the first to
Stoneham but are we answering your
question well
not really you see I don't have a
problem with I'm an elder and I don't
have a problem with praying over people
I just it just has a negative
connotation when I touch their head and
I see that Jesus didn't actually touch a
person's head he touched her eyes He
healed the ear of malcolmus oh I think I
see what you're saying yeah well you're
not required to touch a person's head
when you pray for them there's a lot of
praying that happens in the Bible
without people touching anything and so
you're not required to do that we can't
win past or not loss and I go to India
and folks ask you to pray for them
they'll often point to their head they
want you to place your hand on your your
hand on their heads when you pray
because it does represents transferring
a blessing for them and so I probably
place my hand on thousands of heads in
India but in some cultures they you know
they don't ask for that and there's no
requirement to do that in the Bible I
find no command but you know more in our
culture probably what would be more
appropriate than placing your hand on
somebody's head especially if it's an
adult I know in some cases we pray for
someone in special prayer and we've
placed our hand on their shoulder just
to show you know that you praying for
them and you're lifting them up before
the Lord there's no requirement of
placing your hand on their head by any
means I think more in the culture of the
Middle East like India and time of
Christ and Israel it was more acceptable
and it represented a transfer of
blessing by placing a hand on somebody's
head yeah well that's good because I was
kind of uncomfortable with it because I
read all the stories in Leviticus I
always had a negative connotation but I
would love to pray for someone but I
touch the shoulder or that hand yeah and
I feel more comfortable doing it that
way
well absolutely there's no no problem
with that
we do appreciate your question thank you
but I think we probably need to move
along catch a few more that are standing
in line here all right next caller that
we have is Nathan and Nathan you've got
your question you're on the air I'm hi
there Doug and pastor Ross I appreciate
you taking the call hi all the questions
that you guys answer for thousands of
people we appreciate your
good service is a great great ministry
well thank you the question I have is in
regards to to where are our tithes
supposed to go I know the official
stance of the church is that the tides
go to a main storehouse or a conference
that is managed by the executives or
leadership of the church so I decided to
do a thorough Bible study on what I what
the Bible talks about where the tide is
to be paid and there's new specific
scriptures you can grant me a minute
here to read them these are the ones I
want to specifically have address
because this one these scriptures seems
that the tide can be used for various
sources not just one source for in this
case for the the church leadership or
conference Deuteronomy chapter 14 I'll
read 27 through 29 I'll read I'll read
quickly and the Levite that is within
thy gates thou shalt not forsake him for
he hath no part nor inheritance with
thee at the end of three years thou
shalt bring forth all the tide so here
we were talking about the tide of thine
increase the same year and shalt lay it
up within thy gates verse 29 and the
Levite because he hath no part nor
inheritance with thee and the stranger
and the fatherless and the widow which
are within thy gates shall come and
shall eat and be satisfied that the LORD
thy God may bless thee in all the work
of thine hand which thou doest so here
it seems to acknowledging that the tide
is to be used not only for the Levite
which I would consider that as you know
parallel to the leader of the church but
also the stranger the fatherless and the
widow and then if you turn to
Deuteronomy 26 verse 12 and I'll read 12
and 13 it reiterates the same thing
verse 12 Deuteronomy chapter 26 when
thou has made an end of tithing all the
tithes of thine increase the third year
which
is the year of tithing and has given it
unto the Levite the stranger the
fatherless and the widow the same set of
verses here that they may eat within thy
gates and be filled then thou shalt say
before the Lord thy God this is verse 13
I have brought away the hallowed things
that have died out of mine house and
also have given them unto the Levite and
unto the stranger or to the fatherless
and to the widow the same set of people
according to all thy Commandments which
thou has commanded me
I have not transgressed that commandment
and neither have I forgotten them so my
question is can't the tide be used for
all these different types of sources not
just the Levite per se or the church
leadership of the church good question
let me give you a quick answer if I can
I think that the Bible is talking about
two different tides they had a tithe you
notice this is one that says a third
year most people don't wait three years
to pay their tithe they had a tie that
they would give specifically for the
poor and the fatherless as well as the
Levite this is not going to the priests
I don't think the priests were mentioned
then in this verse and that was a tithe
that was connected with the feasts and
so every third year there was a special
tie that was given just like every
seventh year they were supposed to leave
that land fallow but on an annual basis
and every harvest when they had the
annual spring and harvest feasts the
tide was brought to the storehouse and
distributed from the priests throughout
the priesthood and this is how they
preach the gospel yeah if you look
Nathan just a few verses before in that
same passage verse 22 says you shall
truly tithe all your increase of your
grain that the field produces here by
year so that was a yearly tithe that
would probably go to the gathering point
which would be the temple where the
priests were in addition to that there
was a third year tithe that was also
given to address not only the Levites
but also it says the fatherless and the
widows so it was a special ministry an
outreach that was involved there yeah I
know a lot of people actually pay a
second tithe to
to help with the poor hey Thank You
Nathan we're gonna keep going here and
by the way we do have a lesson that
talks about Tai that's called In God We
Trust and we'll send you a free copy if
you ask for that well you'll need to do
is call our resource phone line that's
eight hundred eight three five six seven
four seven you're gonna ask for the
study guide cold in god we trust' de
Gino amazing fax has a free Bible school
that you can do from the comfort of your
own home it includes 27 beautifully
illustrated study lessons to aid in your
study of God's Word
sign up today for this free Bible study
course by calling 184 four two one five
7,000 that's one eight four four two one
five 7,000 I'm exported that we have is
Jerry listening Oregon Jerry welcome to
the program yes good nice talk dude a
pastor's Ross and Bachelor my question
relates to John chapter three verse one
now a lot of people who are
knowledgeable the Bible or encouraged to
give Bible studies and sometimes people
have suggested that I do that but this
is what it says not many of you should
become teachers my fellow believers
because you know that we who teach will
be judged more strictly do you want
comment on that yeah and that's a James
chapter 3 verse 1 I think he said John
yeah whenever a person and you know I
read that verse yesterday or I actually
heard pastor read it on radio and I'm
always convicted when I hear that verse
because I do a lot of teaching and you
have a great responsibility it's a it's
a privilege to be able to teach the Word
of God but James is saying don't take
that lightly because you are accountable
you know whoever has more responsibility
as more accountability you've just got
to be very careful he's not saying
nobody should be teacher said don't be
anxious say oh I want to be a teacher
you don't realize you're taking up a
very weighty responsibility to be
faithful in communicating the Word of
God because there can be more severe
judgment and if you are miss teaching
people I think it's also relating to the
context here where James is talking to
believers in the church any saying be
care
well don't every believer in the church
claim to be the teacher of the church
you could imagine if you have everyone
claiming to be teachers in the church
there might be some confusion so he says
be very careful if you want to take that
responsibility but in addition to the
teaching that might occur in the church
where you have a teacher teaching a
lesson or the Bible to believers there
is also a teaching that believers give
to those who don't understand the Bible
or who are new to the faith and I think
every Christian is given the Commission
by Christ to go make disciples so there
is also some teaching involved in making
a disciple you want to share your
testimony your own experience but James
I think he's specifically talking about
teachers in the church teaching the
believers they saying be careful of that
assuming that position and that
responsibility yeah do it prayerfully
and carefully because it's it is there's
accountability for doing that hey Thank
You Jerry appreciate your question hope
that helps a little bit who's next
we've got e Frank listening from New
York you Frank welcome to the program
yes
good evening pastor doug and pastor ross
i call tonight because I have a question
of biblical proportions you know the
question is about Jesus Christ when he
was crucified on the cross he spent
three days and three nights in hell I
was informed many years ago by a friend
of the high ranking Islamic Iman that
Jesus Christ never understood what Satan
was so he had to die non propitiation of
our sins but to explore the
understanding of what the universe's
that's what I was informed by the third
high ranking Iman of the Islamic faith
now pastor Doug I want to ask you this
is it true that Jesus died for our sins
and he spent three days and three nights
in hell to do the propitiation and sorry
I have to use the word do but to
propitiate our sins at that time period
in 33
I don't understand the concept of what
the other face that I mentioned is
telling me that Jesus Christ went to
explore what the universe was about
alright thank you Frank I'll do my best
first of all you know I want to be
coming that a question saying well what
does what does the Muslim believe or how
how does Islam feel about Jesus because
first of all they don't believe in the
divinity of Christ they don't believe
that Jesus really died on the cross they
don't think he was betrayed by Judas so
a lot of very clear statements in the
New Testament the Muslims deny they
don't accept that but as far as what
does the Bible say Jesus spent three
days and three nights suffering for the
sins of the world now the penalty for
sin is suffering and death suffering
according to what you deserve and
ultimately the wages of sin is death
Jesus began suffering for our sins and
in Matthew chapter 12 it says as Jonah
was three days and three nights in the
heart of the whale so the Son of Man
would be three days and three nights at
the heart of the earth Jesus began
suffering for our sins Thursday night
when he was betrayed the mob began to
mock him tie him up spit on him pull on
his beard all the way through the
crucifixion crucifixion hanging on the
cross he then died Friday afternoon rose
Sunday morning so that's Thursday night
Friday night Saturday night
wait Rises Sunday morning that's three
days and three nights he wasn't three
days and three nights on the cross or in
the tomb he died Friday and everyone you
know Bible is really clear that he died
on the preparation day and then he wrote
his Sunday morning that's just a little
more than 24 hours
so the suffering of three days and three
nights is when his suffering began
Thursday night repition is a word that
simply means the substitute Christ took
our place he took the punishment that we
deserve we deserve punishment and death
for our sins Jesus took that for us yeah
most specifically to relate to your
question I think you referring to Frank
is where it says he shall not leave he's
his soul in hell but shall raise him I'm
looking Acts chapter 2 verse 31 where it
talks about
according from the Old Testament that he
saw was not left in Hades or Hell nor
did his flesh see corruption the word
hell there is not a place to torment for
the wicked
it simply means the grave the New King
James translates that as Hades which
else was translated as the grave so it's
not referring to place of torment but
rather it's just simply referring to the
grave thank you very much
I know we do have a book on called three
days and three nights and we'll be able
to send that to anyone wanting to learn
more about this all you'll have to do is
call our resource number that's 883 five
six seven four seven and you can answer
the book called three days and three
nights actually Jonah the mean yeah
it's called the sign of Jonah and we'll
be happy to send that to you eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven we have Justin who is listening
from looks looks like North Carolina
Justin welcome to the program good
evening guys thank you for your ministry
thank you in your question I had a quick
question I had a quick question about
actually I have two quick questions so
the first one is you mentioned I heard a
sermon of yours that the vessels are
about in Revelation 7 if you take the
meanings of the names of the tribes it
has like a beautiful message and I and I
wanted to know and I've read that
message I want to know where that came
from and they're a place in the Old
Testament that says with each name of
the tribes mean yes when the women are
when I say the women when Rachel and
Leah are giving birth to their sons and
you know most of that is in what is it
Genesis 1:30 something I saying get one
by one they're having their sons every
time they have and she she has Judah
says I will praise the Lord and and they
make a statement with the birth of each
son okay and you take those statements
and you put them together and this is
what it says this is the names of the
tribes as given in revelation 7 it's the
only place in the Bible the lists of
tribes is in the same order there and it
says now I will praise the Lord for the
Lord has looked on me and granted me
good fortune I'm happy because great
wrestling I have wrestled and prevailed
thus God has made me forget my tour
because the Lord has heard that I am not
loved his joint or married to me and God
has given me my wages or dowry by
dwelling with me and the Lord shall add
to me the son of his right hand so it's
a it's a beautiful statement of the
redemption of the church that is hidden
in the names of the hundred and
forty-four thousand I can give you an
example of one of the verses Genesis
chapter 29 verse 32 where it says so
Leah conceived and bore a son and she
called his name Reuben before she said
the Lord has surely looked upon my
affliction so if you put all of those
different phrases together with
reference to the son it's the
description of what the names mean yeah
and you could look in probably even
google it the the names for all the the
meaning of those Hebrew names are all
given in the Bible and you can look in
any Bible commentary that would have
that one more let me just tell you I've
got a book called who are the hundred
and forty-four thousand we'll send you a
free copy or you can read it online but
you tell you what can you hold your
second question until after our break we
got a break coming up here that is
relentless we can't control it friends
don't go away we're coming back
stay tuned Bible answers live we'll
return in a moment
[Music]
in six days God created the heavens and
the earth for thousands of years man has
worshiped God on the seventh day of the
week now each week millions of people
worship on the first day what happened
why did God create a day of rest does it
really matter what day we worship who is
behind this great shift discover the
truth behind God's law and how it was
changed visit Sabbath truth calm amazing
facts offer some of the best Christian
resources for all ages we help our
products will enrich your life and your
walk with the Lord
what does Bible prophecy reveal about
the world's two largest religions
explore the ancient conflict in Islam
Christianity and prophecy a compelling
three-part series with pastor Doug
Batchelor get yours today by calling
what if you could know the future what
would you do
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking Bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com every bible
question you have answered moves you one
step closer to the fullness of God's
will for your life so what are you
waiting for get the answers you need for
a fuller richer more confident life
you're listening to Bible answers live
this broadcast is a previously recorded
episode if you'd like answers to your
Bible related questions on the air
please call us next Sunday between 7
p.m. and 8 p.m. Pacific time to receive
any of the Bible resources mentioned in
this evening's program call 888-814-3923
mning on facebook it's at the amazing
facts
Facebook page and Doug Batchelor
Facebook page you can watch and listen
and call in with your questions
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and just before the break we
were talking with Justin from North
Carolina Justin welcome back to the
program you had a second question thank
you guys
yeah I'm a believer in the sanctity of
the seventh-day Sabbath but I've heard
at the defense of the Sabbath a
reference in Ezekiel 20:12
they said that you know the stockpile be
a sign of of basically this is a sign
between godness people forever but in
that reference is sadness with us I mean
chloro Sabbath and I thought well I felt
like I've heard that when you see plural
Sabbath
that's not speaking of the seventh-day
Sabbath but that's speaking of the
ceremonial Sabbath so I guess my
question is how can I determine which
Sabbath as there's so many references in
the Bible what each Texas speaking of
when I'm looking for dispense if I'm
having a conversation with other people
about the fact well that's accurate what
you're saying is that in in the zekiel
I'm sorry Ezekiel 20 verse 12 it is
technically talking about Sabbath's in
plural which means that it could include
the Sabbath of the week or Sabbath's
that were Sabbath's that were part of
the annual feasts he really gave them
all to be a sign but certainly the
seventh-day Sabbath is a sign also of
his sanctifying and creative power you
know if you're looking for it's not
always a hard and fast rule but there
are references where God will refer to
the Sabbath as my Sabbath and then God
sometimes refers to the ceremonial
Sabbath's especially when the Israelites
were in a point of rebellion as your
Sabbath so it's kind of interesting
there is that distinction not always but
you do find at times a distinction made
in the Old Testament between my Sabbath
and your Sabbath's in a plural form and
of course we do have a lesson that deals
with the subject of the Sabbath yes
called forgotten day or last day of
history I'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks again the
phone line to our resource is eight
hundred eight three five six seven four
seven you can ask for the last day of
it's one of our amazing facts study
guides and I think you'll find that very
interesting next caller that we have is
let's say we have Myra wait we got Myra
who is calling Myra welcome to the
program Oh may run along hi
yet my hi Myra and your question tonight
um well I primarily just want to thank
you guys for all your service so you
guys do and I do when I just thank doc
bachelor especially in if there's a way
that I could share my testimony with him
through mail or whatever could you
please let me know I would love them
yeah we'd be delighted to hear from you
all you've got to do is if you go to the
amazing facts website it's got a little
note there it says you can contact us
and just say attention pastor Doug and
they do forward those to me I will
definitely do that thank you and my
question is from Luke 16 the rich man
and Lazarus and I was wondering I mean
there's so much controversial about how
as I learned that the dead are and
instead of sleep you know and as any I
shall write and stuff like that so I
still have a hard time trying to
understand this one because I was
brought up to me and I had I was like I
have to pray about and ask God so I was
wondering if there's a way you could
explain it to me sure and just in case
we get disconnected we do have a book a
little sermon book that talks about the
rich man and Lazarus will be happy to
send you this is a parable there's other
parables around it and the reason we
know it's a parable a parable is you
know it's not literal first of all it
says that the beggar dies and goes to
Abraham's bosom we probably are safe and
not believing that everybody who dies
somehow fits into Abraham's bosom that's
a figure of speech then it tells us that
the people in heaven are talking to the
people that are burning in Hades well I
think all of us are hoping that the
saved are not going to be watching
forever the people that are lost and
then the third thing the guy who's in
Hades he says settle
so he can put his finger in a drop of
water and cool my tongue you know that's
hyperbole it's it's not literal this is
a parable now people use this parable to
talk about the state of man and death
and it has nothing to do with the state
of man in death Jesus is doing a
masterful job to use a paradox he has
this poor man who was a symbol for the
Gentiles see the Jews thought because we
feast on the word we've got Abraham we
are the chosen people they were gonna be
saved they were rich he says you think
you're rich and increased with goods in
Revelation and he said you might find
that many will come from the east and
the west and they will sit down in the
kingdom with Abraham Isaac and Jacob and
the natural children some of the Jews
would be on the outside
Christ was warning the Jewish people
back then
you can't just be feasting on the truth
why the Gentiles late your gates
thinking that you're gonna get to the
kingdom so he has the poor man the
Gentile going to Abraham's bosom the
Jewish place of reward and then he has
the rich Jewish man going to the Greek
place of torment Hades in Greek
mythology so Jesus is mixing some irony
and humor in here he's basically saying
you might be in the very opposite place
you think you're gonna be you cannot say
that because I'm a Jew God has to save
me and likewise Christ was saying there
are Gentiles that they would love the
Lord and they want to be in heaven God's
gonna show them mercy because they're
hungry for the bread of life you know I
think there's another lesson here that I
find interesting is where here we have a
parable that somebody is actually named
and the person that's named has the name
of Lazarus and if you read the last part
of the parable the man cries out to
Abraham and he says well I've got five
brothers and if Lazarus were to go to
them and be resurrected from the dead
they'll believe and then the message
comes back well they have Moses and the
prophets if they don't believe them or
believe the scriptures they won't
believe even if someone is resurrected
from the dead now what's amazing is that
shortly after Jesus told this parable he
did resurrect someone from the dead
whose name was Lazarus and still the
religious leaders refused to believe so
the parable the rich man represents the
religious leaders who had all this
wealth and they refused to share it with
the Gentiles who in this parable is
symbolized by the point man
and yet they wouldn't believe even if
Lazarus or when Lazarus was raised from
the dead they still didn't believe and
it's amazing to me that this parable
what the named Lazarus appears before
Jesus does that great miracle Wow okay
so to make sense we do have a book that
deals with the subject of the rich man
and Lazarus and if you call will try and
send you a copy yeah we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks
again the number that you need a call
for our resource is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and just
ask for the book called the rich man and
Lazarus next caller that we have is
Roger and he's listening from Colorado
Roger welcome to the program thank you
for having me I actually have one
question but certain came up earlier on
one of your other persons that called
you up at the Sabbath in the Bible has
has two things one with a capital letter
which I believe is a seventh-day Sabbath
and one with the small letter yes well
you're correct
sometimes it's talking about the Sabbath
of the Ten Commandments and sometimes it
was talking about the annual feasts
which were annual affairs and did not
they were not part of the Ten
Commandments so you're correct sometimes
it's capitalized and sometimes it's
small was that your question or do you
have another one no now now my question
is Jesus has mentioned a few times if
I'm not mistaken the kingdom is at hand
some people are saying that the kingdom
is the physical kingdom and I said wait
a second if the physical kingdom is at
hand why are we still suffering on earth
I says no I believe that physical
kingdom Jesus is talking about is the
spiritual kingdom within us am I am I
wrong with that no you're correct when
Jesus started preaching he said repent
for the kingdom of heaven is at hand
even John the Baptist said the very same
words repent for the kingdom of heaven
is at hand and Christ said for the
kingdom of God is within you if we
invite Jesus to be the king and the Lord
of our lives his kingdom begins in us
right now it's within reach it's at hand
for every person
but the physical kingdom when Jesus was
ascending to heaven in Acts chapter 1
the disciples said Lord will you at this
time establish the kingdom Christ said
it's not for you to know times his
seasons there he was talking about his
second coming where he literally will
reign on the earth that is the literal
Kingdom physical kingdom that hasn't
happened yet the spiritual Kingdom has
happened you know I've heard it
described this way you got two parts to
Christ Kingdom the kingdom of grace
which Jesus announced and the apostles
when Jesus said the kingdom of heaven is
at hand that's the kingdom of grace and
then there is the kingdom of glory and
that's when Jesus comes the second time
and the whole earth at that point
finally after the judgment is recreated
and the Bible says the meek shall
inherit the earth will dwell upon the
earth new jerusalem will be here that's
referencing the kingdom of glory which
is yet to come
right so hope that helps a little bit
Roger it does immensely thank you very
much and pastor Pastor duck I thank you
for Friday night questions also oh good
yeah we're gonna start doing more of
that
we appreciate your giving us a plug for
that thank you thank you very much
god bless bye-bye our next caller that
we have is ginger listening in Loma
Linda ginger welcome to the program hi
good evening evening I have a question
in regards to it's found in Matthew 2:18
as well as jeremiah 31:15
and it says rachel is weeping for her
children refuses to be comforted because
they are dead why why is Rachel weeping
for is like a metaphor I mean I thought
Jesus came from Leah and Judah and this
has nothing to do at that well actually
Rachel who is the mother of Joseph and
Benjamin died in Bethlehem Ephrathah and
this was a prophecy talking about how
the babies in Bethlehem were slain so
rachel is being used as sort of a
metaphorical mother because she died
there giving birth she was giving birth
to Benjamin she died in Bethlehem when
it was still Bethlehem was you know
probably hadn't won Shepard fold back
then there wasn't very little there
later of course David was born there and
ultimately Jesus was born there
then Herod killed all the baby boys in
Bethlehem that were innocent they call
it the slaughter of the innocents
because he was trying to keep the Son of
God from reigning this is a prophecy
about the mothers in Bethlehem weeping
because they lost their children Rachel
did not weep because she died but her
son lived in the other story the
mother's live but the children died so I
think it's a prophecy in matter of fact
Matthew's doing it there is a prophecy
and if you look at the the key of the
whole prophecy why it's even being
quoted again Matthew is the verse 16 and
it's quoting from Jeremiah 31 and after
talks about you know this weeping Rachel
weeping for her children then it says in
verse 16 thus saith the Lord refrain
your voice from weeping and your eyes
from tears for your work shall be
rewarded says the Lord they shall come
back from the land of the enemy so the
Bible speaks of hope for those who those
mothers who lost their children as a
result of the slaughter by Herod and the
promises they will come their children
will come back from the land of the
enemy meaning a resurrection of course
that occurs when Jesus comes the second
time so there's hope even though there
was great pain that the woman went
through there in Bethlehem yes thank you
appreciate your question ginger next
caller that we have let's see we've got
Tyler listening from Ohio Tyler welcome
to the program I really appreciate you
guys and I I was basically raised in a
Freewill Baptist Church and my question
is that why do people believe that hell
is eternal even though there are other
scriptures that don't support that
teaching from the always go to you
verses that they use such as every
lesson in fire or punishment yeah good
question you know there are some
difficult verses but the the vast
preponderance of evidence in the Bible
about what happens to the wicked is that
the wicked will be cast into a lake of
fire and punished according to what they
deserve
he that has done many things wrong
suffers more than he that has done whew
everyone's rewarded according to his
works Jesus said and they are consumed
the the words that you find in the Bible
describing the punishment of the wicked
Malachi chapter 4 it says they are burnt
up Revelation says they are consumed
tells us they are devoured jesus said
they perish jesus said do not fear Him
who can destroy the body but cannot hurt
the soul rather fear him who will
destroy soul and body in hell that's
Matthew chapter 10 and you just start
going through the Bible the Bible says
the wicked will be no more
go to Revelation this is there is no
more pain all things are made new no
more crying
all through the Bible it makes it really
clear the idea that came from the dark
ages and they sort of borrowed it from
Greek mythology where Pluto was in
charge of Hades a place of eternal
torment it was a way to really
manipulate people with fear but the very
idea just think about it a couple of
years ago Isis captured it I think it
was a Jordanian pilot and they
videotaped as they put him in a cage
doused him with gasoline and set him on
fire all of our shudder at the thought
of how cold can someone be to set a man
on fire in a cage in the videotaping and
burning now we're thinking what that's
about as cool and ugly as you can get
and that only happened over a matter of
minutes and yet they think God is going
to do that to the objects of his
creation even though they're rebellious
for eternity and they just think about
eternity that zillions of years go by
moment after moment you're there's
agonizing pain and blistering I mean the
stories that I've heard are sermons
about Hell it's really hard to love a
god like that
so once people know the truth about what
Bible says about Hell it just all starts
to make more sense there are a few
difficult verses where it talks about
eternal punishment
well the punishment is eternal they'd
have no second chance the wicked are
forever gone they're gone forever they
perish the Bible says it's called
eternal fire it's because what the fire
does lasts for eternity so because
a couple of verses that create some
question in people's mind that's what's
often pointed to and they neglect all
the other verses you know we do have a
study guide called is the devil in
charge of Hell and it actually looks at
these verses along with many others and
really gives a clear understanding what
the Bible teaches on the destruction of
the wicked would you give me one quick
quick favor and where in the bible does
it say that jesus will reward everybody
according to what they deserve
revelation 22 he comes with him and his
reward he's with him to give to every
man according to his works I think it's
also in Revelation 1:7 behold he comes
with the clouds
well that's everyone everyone yeah yeah
revelation 22 is where it says with
reward according to their works
okay you guys thank you all right god
bless if you enjoy hearing solid
biblical answers on Bible answers live
you can have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy study Bible the updated
hardcover version is available at its
lowest price ever and includes the
complete set of amazing facts 27 study
guides plus a Bible numbers and symbols
charts and eight pages of colorful maps
this best-ever Bible gives you a
biblical cyclope 'dick index words of
Christ in red chronology of the Old
Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five thirty eight seventy two seventy
five next quarter that we have is
michelle listening in santa barbara
Michelle welcome to the program hi guys
it's good to hear from you uh pastor
Doug and Pastor John special Mendoza oh
hey so I got a question to ask you guys
I know that there's much discussion
regarding the abortions right now and
all that mean legalized and the
Christian method and whatnot but as we
all know that sin
is a freedom of choice that's right
right since freedom but he got you know
he give us free will to people to sin
yes yes okay so what happens if I or any
other female is brutally raped I never
chose to be raped but I got rate and I
tried to fight my way out but I couldn't
and I got your third yes and his sin is
a freedom of choice
and that person chose to abuse me I
could not consent to have intercourse
with God how does God look at that do if
I get pregnant must I be forced to carry
a child that I never consented to have
all right great question great question
at the heart of that you are recognizing
that a rape of is a horrific and a
violent experience so once that happens
when conception takes place that now
becomes human life even though it was
not done through choice that's human
life now that is a miraculous process
that God has designed where a new life
is formed in his image the way you solve
a brutal or violent act is not with a
second brutal or violent act the Bible
tells us that a son should not pay for
the sins of the father and a father for
the children's sins if a man rapes a
woman should the baby now be the one who
will lose its life because that terrible
experience and I think as soon as you
start making creating openings for
saying yeah this is you know if abortion
is wrong it's wrong because human life
is sacred and life begins at conception
if life begins at conception then it
must be respected but keep in mind
there's a lot of history is full of
stories including the Bible of people
who got off the wrong start and yet God
did something wonderful with their lives
I can think of one of the judges of
Israel by the name of Jeff though he was
illegitimate and we don't know if that
was a result of rape or not but mother
chose not to terminate her pregnancy and
he ended up becoming a judge and a great
big deliverer in Israel and then you can
look at the story of lot who slept with
his daughters and that was a terrible
thing to do and some people say incest
is a reason for abortion well it turns
out that lot's daughter one of them had
a son named Moab who became an ancestor
of Jesus for the Ruth
and so if you start saying we're gonna
abort babies from rape and then set you
assess you you can eliminate the savior
of the world that way so I think even
though it's a terrible experience I
think still we should you know maybe
adoption but killing the child I don't
think it's ever the answer and I thank
you Michele good question a difficult
question next caller that we have is
wolfred listening from new york Wolford
welcome to the program hi pastor that
were you all doing great thank you for
calling got about four three minutes
your question my question is is the
rapture and the second coming last price
the one and the same event yes the word
rapture means to be caught up the Bible
tells us of the Lord and this is first
Thessalonians chapter four the Lord
Himself will descend from heaven with a
shout the voice of the Archangel the
Trump of God the dead in Christ will
rise and when they arise and then it
says we who are alive will be caught up
that's the rapture to meet them in the
air so when the Lord comes we are caught
up to meet him in the air Jesus said in
John 14 I go to prepare a place for you
and if I go I will come again and
receive you unto myself that where I am
also so they are one in the same and we
have a book we can send you for free and
it's called anything but secret it talks
about the rapture and the second coming
and if you just call the resource not
align anything but secret we'll send
that to you number to call is 808 three
five six seven four seven and again you
can ask for the study guide called
anything but secret actually it's a book
and we'll be happy to send it out to
anybody who calls and asks deals with
the second coming and what it means it
talks about the rapture what that means
again we'd encourage you to call and ask
for that it looks like we have time for
one more caller and who do we have
pastor day number seven maybe you've got
number seven Robin is listening in
Michigan wrong we have just a few
minutes left hey pastor doug and pastor
ross hi good to be talking tonight and
your question my question before that i
just wanted to give a quick greeting
from michigan i'm as well as a hello
from a friend of mine pastor chad
bernard here in michigan I understand he
works with you
great yes okay so my question is from
deuteronomy chapter 14 and it pertains
to the strong drink referenced in verse
26 and my question is I believe that God
doesn't want us to consume alcoholic
beverages so taking that into
consideration how does this strong drink
relate to tithing mention in the
greatest verses and what is its purpose
yeah well the words strong drink strong
can mean you know we think a strong
drink is alcoholic sometimes it uses
that phrase to describe an alcoholic
drink sometimes the word strong there
can simply mean concentrated the the
Jews had a very popular way it was very
common for them to dehydrate their their
grape juice and it they would condense
it because it was a lot easier to
transport liquid if it's condensed
that's why they've got to concentrate
orange juice because when you ship
orange juice you know water weighs what
eight pounds a gallon it was so much
lighter if they took about half the
moisture out of it then reconstituted it
and so they would take this concentrated
grape juice that wasn't fermented
sometimes even like a paste full of
sugar it kept it from decomposing and
then they'd reconstitute it with water
and drink it later that was never as
good as the fresh wine that's why they
said to Jesus in John chapter two you
saved the best for the last where do you
get fresh wine this time of year so
strong drink did not always mean
alcoholic sometimes it simply meant
there a grape juice paste that they
would then reconstitute hmm all right
now I've got a book on this I can send
you a free copy it's called alcohol and
the Christian and it's got the
references and just go to our resource
line and we'll be happy to send that to
you the number to call for the resource
line is 883 five six seven four seven
and again you can just ask for the book
called alcohol and the Christian will be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks well friends we're gonna probably
not have time to take another question
but let me just mention something you
may have heard a commercial earlier in
the program amazing facts has a
wonderful Bible called the prophecy
Study Bible filled with resources and a
lot of the answers you hear on this
program
if you go to the amazing facts bookstore
you'll find that there and it will be a
blessing
right let us know if you enjoy the
program and if you can make a donation
keep us on the air we appreciate it
god bless
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts a faith-based
ministry located in Sacramento
California
okay friends let's start with the basics
we know we're here but we're not here
for very long so the most important
thing would be if we could learn during
this life how to live forever this is
the central focus of amazing facts
there's a lot of wonderful things that
Christian ministries do I believe in
Christian education but if the school's
lose the message of salvation you end up
with more educated sinners I think it's
very important for us to build churches
but if the churches lose the message of
salvation they just become buildings and
shells I think it's important to have a
medical ministry and build hospitals but
if they separate that from the message
of salvation you just prolong a sinners
life for a little while that's why for
years amazing facts has made it our
focus to present the saving truth that
sets people free and friends we want to
thank you for your support in your gifts
we'll do our very best to convert those
resources into the currency of heaven
may God bless you and keep amazing facts
in your prayers want to know God's plan
for our world and solutions for your
life's challenges
beautifully redesigned amazing facts 27
Bible study guides provide encouraging
Bible based answers to questions on
healthier relationships when Jesus will
return and much more refer to watch
while you read our brand new prophecy
encounters DVD series makes the perfect
companion set order your study guides
and DVDs today by visiting AAF bookstore
com or by calling 857 275 written by the
hand of God
and spoken with his voice
some words will never fade
yet pastor Doug bachelors twelve part
sermon series on the Ten Commandments by
calling 805 three eight seven 275 or
visit AF bookstore comm have you ever
wondered how can I share Jesus with my
Jewish friends amazing faxes recently
produced a fascinating three-part DVD
series called is Jesus kosher for Jews
in these new programs three Jews Steve
Wahlberg Jeff sir Minsky and myself
relate our personal encounter with a
Christian faith so pick up a copy today
for yourself and share one with your
Jewish friends call 800 five three eight
seven 275 or visit us at AAF bookstore
com to get yours if you'd like to
enhance your study of God's Word
visit our website at WWF as a RG and
sign up for our free Bible study course
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore comm which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]